President Trump is expected to roll out
new tariffs targeting China as soon as
this week they would be in addition to
steel and aluminum tariffs said to go
into effect this Friday those measures
would boost the cost of steel imports
from China and many other countries by
25 percent aluminum would cost 10% more
Ben Tracy is in Beijing with how China
is reacting to the possibility of a
trade war and good morning a good
morning so these new tariffs of the
Trump administration is considering are
said to specifically target Chinese
Goods and we're talking everything from
electronics to clothing now there was a
news conference here in Beijing today
with China's premier that's the
number-two leader in this country and he
said that he wants the u.s. to quote act
rationally and not be led by emotions he
says China doesn't want a trade war and
if there is one there aren't going to be
any winners now China has said if the
u.s. does impose tariffs on Chinese
goods
it will protect itself but has not said
what specific retaliation it may take
against us products that are exported
here to China now big targets could be
American soybeans and aerospace
equipment President Trump has long
criticized China for its trade practices
calling them unfair and accusing the
Chinese of stealing American technology
now we should note that the u.s. does
have a trade deficit with China of 385
billion dollars and President Trump has
urged the Chinese to shave at least 100
billion dollars off of that Gail alright
Ben Tracy reporting from Beijing we
thank you